- Du personnel surchargé,
qui s'occupe d'un trop grand
est critique, affirment douze
groupes qui représentent
notamment les infirmières.
JÉRÔME ROUSSEAU, v.-p., Féd.
interprofessionnelle santé QC
de donner l'ensemble des soins,
de faire l'entièreté de leur
travail et ça, ça a urururururus
personnes.
- Pour améliorertététété
des soins prodigués et les
conditions de travail,
ils réclament l'adoption de
normes qui déf l l l l le nombre
maximal de patients dont peuvent
s'occuper les professionnels
de la sant
- On demande au gouvernement
d'in r r r r r r r r r r r r r c
des équipes de soins en nombre
t t t t t pour chacun des unités
de soins, chacun des milieux
de soins au Québec, que ce soit
LUC MATHIEU président, Ordre des
infirmières, infirmier
structurante la pratique
infirmière puis la
des soins dans les réseau de
la santé, une loi sur les ratios
minimum, c'est uerererererereres
ce sens-là.
que les salles d'urgence
débordent dans plusieurs
hôpitaux.
KENZA RAHMI, Association québ.
infirmières et infirmiersl'unite
par exemple, va permettre
à ce que l'urgence soit moins
débordée. Parce que les lits
vont être disposibles
dans d'autres unités.
- Le gouvernement Couillard
avait lancé des projets-pilotes
patients-infirmières.uxuxuxuxuxé
à l'hôpital de Hull,
en. . . . . . À l'urgence,
une infirmière s'occupait d'un
maximum de quatre patients.
c'est qu'une infirmière peut
avoir 10 des fois 15 patients
dans une urgence, doutututututut
générer, inévitablement ça a
des conséquences
- En mai 2020, les libéraux
sésésésésésésé un projet de loi
pour établir des ratios dans
le systulululululululululululult
n'a pas voulu l'adopter.
MONSEFrtrtrtrtrtrtrte-parole
de l'opposition en santé
- Si le gouvernement ne légifère
enenenenenenenenenenenenenenenes
garantir un accès aux soins d d.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre de la
Sant s s s s s s s s s s s s s e
à des ratios si on n'a pas
e e e e e e e de personnel, faut
mettre les choses dans l'ordre.
C'est une question deatatatatatn
collective et elle commenceraro.
- Les 12 groupes qui réclament
une loi, rétorquent quepopopopor
et retenir davantage
de travailleurs dans le système
que l'expérience l'a prouvé
en Californie et en Australie.
Ici Olil.l.l.l.l.l.l.l.l.l.l.l.